مع دعوات وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
والهدنات التي لا تدوم الا قليلا تصاعدت
مخاوف حول دخول مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه
الروسيه على خط الصراع دعم باسلحه من قوات
فاجنر ما هي دقه هذه المعلومات اولا
بالنسبه لكم سياده الفريق
برهان على سؤال حول وجود فاغنر في السودان
في لقاء مع قناه العربيه في الثاني
والعشرين من هذا الشهر اما دجلو فعند
سؤاله عن علاقه الدعم السريع بالمجموعه
العسكريه الخاصه فقد انكر
اول المعبرين عن قلقهم من وجود محتمل
لمرتزقه فاغنار كان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
مقابل القلق الامريكي موقف رسمي روسي
يتجاهل المخاوف الامريكيه
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف اعتبر
تعامل الدول الافريقيه مع فاغنر كشركه
خاصه شانا داخليا وان لها الحق في ذلك
ولكن لم يتبين حتى الان ما اذا كان
لمرتزقه
وجود على الميدان في السودان
انسنا ماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات